entra veloce che c'è chi c'e dietro
molto bene perfetto perché è passato a
schermo intero il video questo successo
mi ha cambiato
mi ha anche cambiato i settaggi di ubs
stesso jobs che questo jobs che era
talmente forte che ha fatto dell'editing
mica non avevano piazzato mezzo visto
gioco quando non me l'aspettavo mai in
questo momento gara complimenti
vi ringrazio sono ringraziare ho perso
vent'anni di vita in questo momento
vabbè andiamo avanti ragazzi ottimo
comunque sono molto contento di beccarmi
jump square uno ogni 4 secondi i
complimenti il demonio
era una visione cos'era vabbè allora va
alzato il coso secchio e teoricamente
rilanciato fortissimo ma si abbassa
[Musica]
perché nera anche un altro magari la
giunta mette un'ora e mezza teoricamente
dovrei riuscirci ragazzi ce n'è un altro
ce l'ha fatta
pensi è perfetto perfetto prefetto
stesso dove maria in tutto questo
porca vacca no ragazzi se diventano
veramente impossibile da gestire il suo
gioco porco demonio
basta fare climbing sui palazzi che
fastidio
fammi finire st parte li mettono ansia
incredibile nora che mi sono veramente
cagato addosso cioè il numero possa
creare sono veramente kfar me la sono
fatta nei pantaloni fortissimo
ecco come non è a posto meraviglioso
quello che non dovrà succedere però
visto un saltato fortunatamente l'ho
fatta mia finito dio ti ringrazio
oltrepassa la palude per arrivare a casa
di maria maria
eccola qua la prossima casa che prendi
cerca per cortesia di prenderla
in centro vicino al duomo non nelle
palle perché poi è difficile per me è
capito io mi sforzo incredibile barche
in arrivo perfetto
tutto è bene quel che finisce bene
corri ma lanciato una barca addosso va
bene non me lo aspettavo una paura e la
ok anche viene ucciso ho chiuso o chiuso
a ok può aprire può aprire coprire per
finché può aprire non posso sta
tranquillo via via via lia dior caputo
corri corri maria la prossima volta
freddi una casa in centro per cortesia
ok noi che giro destra ok perfetto
ragazzi cioè ingestibile il tuo giorno
succedono cose ogni 4 secondi
sono morto sono morto no non mi sono
morto non salta sopra è stupido io ci ho
provato lo giuro ci ho provato ho visto
che mancava e si dette di una scena in
due mari di scrivimi su whatsapp prima
possiamo passare un po più di tempo
nella palude non perché mi sto
divertendo cioè proprio salve la trovo
un passatempo bello ce l'abbiamo fatta
casa di maria farfa niente ce n'è
un'altra volta bene pro bello mi sono
divertito
facciamo un'altra volta quando ricapita
maria il tuo maria maria maria mi qua
sono io sono lorenzo quello che fai
video dovevo fare un video maria a tutti
ragazzi in un tipo maria comunque non ho
capito
il tutto questo quanta roba esiste in
questa foresta c è incredibile
c'è una civiltà non era foresta come è
possibile comunque la gente che piange
negli horror è sempre ben accetta questa
è casa di maria diaries bene ma mi sa
che questa è casa non è vero se maria e
casa di maria ok preparò allegra la casa
meno male almeno quella ecco la bara
pensate che egocentrica ci aveva
molestato due giorno però potresti la
parte dalla faccia la mattina il nome di
tuo figlio stata la notte ero satana no
satana non lo si nomina non si apre la
porta io ho provato ad aprirla
ho provato la prima l'avaria così apre
nel nome di cristo fincapital a farcelo
passa di qua e la madonna proprio le
porte brandizzate basta ho capito se
esce
chi li ha portati a quando non sbaglia e
va bene va bene ho capito che la vera
dice passata attraverso madonna e la
ristrutturazione chiuso eccola figure
mappe che a maria sempre avuto la chiave
su di lei
consiglio quindi ma figurati se posso
rubarle la chiave a maria io non rubo
proprio niente
ma cosa per l'asta porta posso fare pic
loc ok mi che ormai sono sperto
scassinatore visto gioco
vai a ma devo cruch armi di sotto e
andare dietro di lei
se si gira all'improvviso io sono morto
completamente la porta alla porta quando
lasciò la roma chiude non l'ha chiusa si
era bloccata con un bug orribile stai
zitto ti rimetti anzi a chiudi le porte
non sono se non sono al sicuro qui ma
veramente zio grazie che me l'hai detto
scappa e va bene ciao mari è andato a
finire
che schifo o ciò che ci sono i nostri ai
avvocato maria ma poi poi mai finire
così ma veramente potevi farlo prima
demonio grazie maria che si è diventata
un alga alga maria quindi alla fine è
stato il demonio cioè quindi dovrò
andare colpo a qualcuno alla fine è
stato il demonio eccolo satana è stato
satana è stato l'uomo mascherato picchia
con la barca il segmento con la barca va
ok ci divertiamo lo stesso ragazzo la
barca l'importante è trovare il
colpevole che ti tutti sti episodi per
si pensava fosse la sua famiglia ma
errata no no
e stato lui però doveva dircelo proprio
maria non poteva dirmelo senza incorrere
mia e tentare di uccidermi ma doveva
dirmelo così ok non credo che questa
barca sia tra le più sicure del mondo
però proviamoci
si no
io sto veramente smettendo di farmi
domande
sto smettendo di farmi domande
quello lì mi aveva incappucciato in casa
come sono finito in una macchina in
fondo ad un lago
come è possibile spiega mila il senso di
questo gioco come faccia uscire c'è la
macchina il finestrino non sia pro le
portiere tutto al contrario come fa
niente io morirò qua dentro perché non
riesco a fuggire dalla macchina ottimo
parkaue si può che ogni transizione che
fanno è una roba allucinante che qua
dietro a corpo morto dicono del pozzo
carino non si può uscire a meno che non
ci sia un tasto per l'aprile le mail e
le robe avidi a nokia che ok c'è una
spranga con la quale faccio leva madonna
in una vita reale sarai morto otto volte
respiro un decimo di questo meraviglia
prendi la pistola gioiese una pistola li
la prendi la prendiamo la pistola non
politici ma veramente ma mi rende
orgoglioso così pro bello comunque
allegro a noi serviva proprio il
finestrino va bene io avrei usato anche
per dopo torna a galla due ore per
quelli nostra comunque bellissimo che le
transizioni sono non hanno senso
prima stavo sulla barca si è inseguire
tizio mascherato scommettete che poi non
ci tornerò mai più
prima o poi mi hanno incappucciato sotto
il fitto nel lago come spiegano al tipo
che mia incappucciato mia mi ha fatto mi
ha messo alla guida della mia macchina e
mi ha fatto quasi per uscire sì devo
tornare a casa per l'ennesima volta che
ho lasciato emma da sola per l'ennesima
volta fa niente
riccione
[Musica]
no